real-time map features are part of some
of the most successful apps in the world
such as uber waves and Pokemon go in
this episode I'm going to show you how
to start building your own real-time map
features using the map Box API with
angular 4 on the front end and firebase
on the back end the demo you're looking
at here allows users to post messages on
the map that are associated with
specific GPS coordinates and the user
can click on the message and fly to
wherever those GPS coordinates happen to
be the important thing to notice here is
that the data in firebase in the map or
staying in sync in real time so any user
observing this map will have access to
the latest data as soon as it's saved to
the firebase database before we get into
the code I want to share a helpful
tutorial from West while he spends a
full hour building a RunKeeper inspired
angular 4 app which is a great resource
if you're working with map box you can
find a link in the description below the
first step is to sign up for a free map
box account and then retrieve your API
access token during the initial setup
map box should give you a link to the
CSS that you can include any index.html
file and then you'll want to add your
X's token to your environment file then
you can run npm install map box - GL
netflix has some good default maps out
of the box but you can customize them to
an infinite number of combinations in
this case I'm using that cartogram app
to mimic the color pattern in an image
and you can use the map box editor to
customize all the finer details within
the map one thing that's really
important when working with any
geolocation data is to make sure it
follows a consistent format in this
example we're going to create a type
script interface to ensure that it
follows the geo JSON spec geolocation
data is often shared between multiple
platforms so we want to make sure our
app is following the same spec that
every other API is going to follow the
most important aspect here is the
geometry which is just the GPS
coordinates of a given location we're
also going to create a feature
collection class which is part of the
geo JSON spec and it's essentially just
an array of geo JSON data now we can
start building the service the service
is going to serve two purposes first it
will initialize the map with the API key
and it will also handle all the data
retrieval and updating with firebase so
we import the angularfire database as
well as our geo JSON class and the map
box GL library then we can add the
access token from our environment to map
box in the constructor the get markers
method will just return a firebase list
observable and then when we create a
marker it'll have our geo JSON format
and it will go to that markers list and
lastly we add a method to remove a
marker now we can build the component
there's going to be a lot going on here
so I recommend pausing the video or
checking out the full lesson on angular
firebase comm to really get a full grasp
of everything after importing the matte
box library and our map service we
defined a variable for the map itself
then add some default values for the map
style and the latitude and longitude the
source variable will be the live
connection with map box and the markers
will supply the data that updates that
source we inject the service and the
constructor and then retrieve the
markers from firebase during ng on a net
then we'll initialize the map but first
let's check out the HTM we have a div
with an ID of map this did will be
replaced with the contents the map
itself then we loop over all the markers
in the database when the user clicks on
a marker it'll fly to that location on
the map and they also have the option to
remove a marker and the last thing we'll
do is add a text input for the user to
enter the message they want placed on
the map
this will just be bound to the message
variable with ng model so the end result
is the user types in a message clicks
the map and that appears on the message
as well as being saved to firebase then
any user observing this data can click
it and it'll fly to that exact location
so now back in the type script when we
initialize a map we want to figure out
the user's location if possible and
center the map on their exact location
if we can we do that by calling
navigator dot geo location and that will
give us a promise and when that promise
returns it should have the coordinates
of that user then we can use the fly to
method from map box to fly to that
location to define the map variable we
call the map class and pass some
configuration options to it
the container corresponds to the div
with an ID of map in the HTML net blocks
also has a bunch of optional parameters
you can pass here so check those out in
the documentation you can also add
additional features to the app here we
add some additional navigation controls
in addition to that you can register
event listeners here we listen for the
click event which will return the GPS
coordinates of wherever that user
clicked so we can then use that to
update the firebase database first we
convert it to geo JSON format and then
we add an optional message parameter
that's the message the user enters in
the forum and then we send that to the
firebase database so at this point we
just need to connect this real-time data
stream with the math itself when it's
finished loading it'll trigger the load
event and then we can start connecting
that stream so we call add source on the
map with the name of firebase and just
pass it an empty geo JSON feature
collection and we can set the source as
a variable on the component itself to
start beating data to the source we
subscribe to the markers observable then
we convert the data to a future
collection and call set data on the
source that will push the latest data to
the end-user viewing the map at this
point we just need to define some
styling for the markers themselves
Netflix has a very large API for
defining all these Styles so you can
pretty much customize them to look any
way you want you can also interpolate
any data that was added to the
properties field of the geo JSON itself
which we're doing here with the message
with single curly braces and now just to
wrap this up we'll add a couple of
helper methods to remove markers as well
as fly to various locations on the map
now we should be able to type in the
text and then add it to the map by
clicking on whatever location we want
and have everything updated in real time
that's it for real-time maps with map
box if this video helped you please like
and subscribe and if you want to support
the channel consider becoming a pro
subscriber at angular firebase comm you
can talk to me directly on our Black
team and I'll help you figure out
whatever custom map integration you're
going for thanks for watching and I'll
see you next time
[Music]